[Music]
this is a CBS News special report I've
turned to copal in New York the Labor
Department's newest weekly report on
jobless claims shows the coronavirus is
continuing to hurt the US economy the
last two reports were historic they
showed around 10 million Americans had
filed for unemployment that is more jobs
lost in a matter of two weeks than in
the entire 18 months of the Great
Recession the new report out this
warning shows 6.6 million additional
Americans filed jobless claims in the
prior week that matches the week before
which was a record CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger joins us to dig
through these numbers Jill good morning
so we were hearing estimates of up to 7
million we're in a little bit under that
is that good news or was just as
catastrophic as the past two weeks I
think it's terrible news across the
board and now that we see these numbers
in broad daylight they even look worse
for these three weeks now I just want to
put this in context during the entire
recovery from the Great Recession the US
economy added about 20 million jobs we
are nearing those job losses just in
three or four weeks so this is a
staggering report the previous week was
revised a little bit higher so even
worse for the previous week the records
continued to just blow the minds of
every economist and every American who
sees the numbers come in some of whom
are feeling it day to day in their lives
yeah when economists review these these
numbers they use terms like
mind-boggling the bonkers I mean very
unscientific terms these are
once-in-a-generation
figures retail restaurants hospitality
those have been the industry's hit
hardest first where is this crisis going
from here well I think the good news is
that when we kind of push forward we
were likely we will likely see the
tapering off of these numbers what we
don't know is just how long people are
going to be sidelined it's such a
strange thing about the health pandemic
because in order to get to this route
cause of the financial problem we've got
to cure the health problem to cure the
health problem businesses have to
shutter we have to stay home that makes
these numbers these economic reports
terrible but we really must do this in
order to safely see the return of
workers to their payrolls I'm hopeful
that some of the Small Business
Administration loads will bring some of
these folks who are sidelined back onto
their payrolls they won't go to work but
at least they'll be getting paid during
this time unemployment is supposed to
cushion a period like this for Americans
who need it and in fact the federal
government has added to that cushion
$600 a week but we hear reports of
people struggling to get access to those
benefits what's the holdup
well these systems that are run through
the states we're not built to process 15
16 million people over the course of
just three weeks there's also the
problem that many states have these
legacy mainframe technology systems that
have not been kept up to date you know
it's like anything else when times are
going well you don't invest in the
things you don't think you need the
technology that supports the state
unemployment systems they're old and
they need help and hopefully when the
government adds money to state coffers
this will be an area where we see some
improvement but right now it is
incredibly frustrating for those who are
trying to get these much-needed
unemployment benefits all right Jill
Schlesinger thank you very much and this
is not a repeat six million additional
Americans lost their jobs in the past
week according to new numbers out just
this morning our coverage will continue
on our 24-hour streaming network cbsn
you can watch it at CBS news.com or on
the CBS News app there will be more to
come on your local news on the CBS
station and of course tonight on the CBS
Evening News with Norah O'Donnell many
of you will now return to CBS this
morning this has been a CBS News special
report
I'm Tony - Koppel CBS News New York